[Music]
all right oh my gosh give it up for the
B
Matthew oh my gosh I always like to
close out with one last story I hope
that you'll enjoy this is what I'm
liking I am so excited to now be living
here in New York you have no idea it's
the largest understatement ever but I am
not the only one y'all are loving to
hear people having a good time right yes
yes all right that made me feel really
good when people said that cuz it was LE
know my decision um was K have gone
poorly uh a few days ago though our
vocal director Jesse had a magical
moment walking down the street our
senior supervising digital producer Andy
caught it in its full glory and I made
her let me play it check out this gym
Jesse posted on
[Music]
Instagram it's 5
it's
[Applause]
Welcome to New York
[Music]
baby my favorite thing
ever I she showed me this and I was like
oh my gosh I love New York so much what
happened Those Were Strangers Those Were
Strangers Andy Andy and I went out for a
drink yes so like
a place on his block and we walked in we
were just going to get like a drink with
his friends that were in town and we
walked in and it was a full drag show so
obviously we
stayed and anyway so then I I left and
we were in the street and you were on a
stage
sober and I was just practicing my best
Drag walk and then next thing I know
there was a whole crowd of people
cheering me on I Love New York it's the
best for perfect
strangers
thank you Jesse for allowing me to play
that I love it so much I'm liking your
post right now now around this point we
usually give our guests $1,000 courtesy
of our season long partner pilot pin
makers of friction they go to erasable
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show and I
know the Jess is like wait what but
sadly we are not able to give that to
people who work here wow so I'm gonna
buy her a really nice gift so their
their loss is going to be the gain for
someone in the audience though so I want
you to look at the Monitor and our
cameras are going to do a little magic
and one of your faces is going to show
up right there so okay hit it let's do
it face face
face your eyes got so big what's your
name Louie Lou what's up what are you
going to do with the grand
go on vacation with my fiance
yes I love that we'll have such a
beautiful life together thank you all
for coming and congrats on the grand
thank you so much we're such huge fans
oh you thank you I'm a fan of Jess right
now yes ma'am um thank you to all our
guests this hour Sam Hugh and Janet
Kramer Matthew and Grace and cila y'all
have a great B if it's not try and Chang
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home